we're America we can say anything the
fuck we want and no one can stop us and
that's great in I guess in any political
time I think the ability to poke fun at
you know the leader is or whatever the
supposed leader is yeah it's valuable is
it's not just a stress release it's a
way of you know I don't I'm not one of
these people she's a whole bunch of
nobility and comedy I'm not you know
this is this great art and this
important thing we do but it's nice it's
funny it's a good thing it's a good
thing it's it's really it really is
important in democracy to be able to do
that I'm an absolutist on free speech I
think once we can't make fun of our
leaders yeah as long as we make fun of
our leaders I'm okay once we can't make
fun of the leaders and then I'm
concerned about where we're going I
people sometimes confuse I think legally
you should be able to say anything you
want and but then again and I think if
you're seeing that someone is booked on
a TV show that you don't agree with I
think it's not against free speech it's
not you're not violating anyone's free
speech to say I don't want to be in a
program with that person or if your
publishing house is publishing a book by
someone you don't like if there's no
violation of free speech it's not you're
not impinging on anyone to say I don't
care to be associated with that person
that's fine I'm worried I'm worried when
I see people get in trouble for slips of
the tongue
I'm worried when I see interpretation
being used to hurt people the list of
words that you cannot say seems to grow
it's never gonna get smaller it's never
gonna be like well actually you know
what go ahead with that one like we're
cool with that I think it's fantastic
when you know oppressed groups like sort
of reclaim words like when the queer
community made queer like their word ago
they said all right you can you can
apply that label to us fine well you
know we'll take pride and what we'll
slap it on ourselves and you know I
think every group does that to a certain
extent or has learned from that example
but once that little demon gets in your
head and says die I can't say that you
know we're screwed I worry when there's
talk of limiting speech
and I worry when I look I worry I sound
like a grandmother
I don't like hate speech laws I'm
vehemently against them
I think there is anti-american and
anti-democratic as anything can be and I
don't like the idea of criminalizing
thought no matter how hateful or stupid
the thought is it sounds like something
from 1984 I don't think we make the hate
go away by not saying it I'm you know
I'm basically I'm Lenny Bruce and Harry
Potter I will say Voldemort's name you
know it doesn't make Voldemort go away
to not say that fucking word I always
curse too much on these things I think
I'm sorry you know the road health paper
with great intentions like I get it but
it is it's a bad path for us and there's
a problem if things are so chaotic now
things are at such a high tenor people
are so filled with vitriol that it's
very possible that you know just to get
everyone to cool down you know this is
this is when this kind of stuff to get
through but I would it would that would
not be American
[Music]